monsieur blanc je vous souhaite la
bienvenue et vous remercie vivement de
votre disponibilité pour répondre à nos
questions nous avons entamé les travaux
de notre commission d'enquête sur
l'identification des défaillances de
fonctionnement au sein des fédérations
françaises de sport du monde sportif et
des organismes de gouvernance du monde
sportif le 20 juillet dernier
l'Assemblée nationale choisit de créer
cette commission d'enquête à la suite de
très nombreuses révélations publiques de
sportives et sportifs et de divers
scandales judiciaires ayant très à la
gestion de certaines fédérations comme
celle du football nos travaux se décline
donc autour de trois axes
l'identification des violences physiques
sexuelles ou psychologiques dans le
sport l'identification des
discriminations sexuelles et raciales
dans le sport et l'identification des
problématiques liées à la gouvernance
financière des fédérations sportives et
des organismes de gouvernance du monde
sportif bénéficiant d'une délégation de
service public
si le football français fait rêver la
France grâce à ses champions du monde
dont vous faites partie l'écosystème du
football pose en revanche des problèmes
et là en effet été traversé à plusieurs
reprises par des défaillances parfois
majeures concernant les trois
problématiques qui nous occupent l'on
peut citer notamment le scandale
football leaks en 2016 relatifs aux
pratiques d'évasion fiscale de la part
de certains footballeurs étrangers ou
plus récemment l'éviction du président
de la FF et de la FFF monsieur Noël le
Great suite à ses propos polémiques
envers Zinédine Zidane couplé aux
accablantes accusations de harcèlement
moral et sexuel de la part de plusieurs
femmes travaillant à ses côtés et le
manager contesté de sa directrice
générale madame Hardouin Florence lors
de son audition le journaliste romain
Molida a estimé à propos de la éviction
de Noël de great à la tête de la FFM je
cite en France on s'attaque à une
personne généralement les présidents
mais ce sont les systèmes et ceux
bénéficiaires selon lui serait tous
l'écosystème du football en particulier
au sein de la FF mais plus largement au
niveau de la FIFA qui favoriserait ce
type de défaillance systémique vous-même
vous avez déclaré en 2020 dans
l'émission Téléfoot que le football
était en train de prendre une direction
qui ne vous plaît pas en raison
notamment de la spéculation que ces
clubs réalisent sur les joueurs je vous
cite on demande aux aidraineurs de faire
preuve de la valeur aux joueurs en les
on les achète 10 pour les revendre 30 ou
40 quel bilan tirez-vous de vos
observations du milieu du football
depuis près de 40 ans
diriez-vous que la situation a empiré ou
c'est au contraire améliorer concernant
les situations de violence de
discrimination et l'évolution de la
gouvernance des instances nationales et
internationales quel serait vos
recommandations auprès des politiques
que nous sommes pour faire évoluer
positivement
le contexte je vous remercie d'avance de
la qualité de vos réponses et vos
rappels que cette audition est ouverte à
la presse et retransmise en direct sur
le site de l'Assemblée nationale
ad avant de vous laisser la parole et
d'entamer nos échanges pendant environ
1h30 je vous rappelle que l'article 6 de
l'ordonnance du 17 novembre 1958
relative au fonctionnement des
assemblées parlementaires imposent aux
personnes entendues par une commission
d'enquête de prêter serment de dire la
vérité toute la vérité rien qui la
vérité je vous invite donc à lever la
main droite et à dire je le jure après
avoir activé votre micro ce quelqu'un
je vous remercie et vous avez la parole
Monsieur Laurent Blanc
bonjour à tous bonjour à toutes
je vous ai écouté avec la tension
je pense j'espère que je veux notre
dialogue va être flippé de questions et
de réponses
parce que tout ce que vous venez de
d'évoquer et très large
et donc à partir de là c'est des sujets
de c'est des sujets qui représentent
beaucoup de d'avis et j'ai certainement
un avis aussi mais j'aimerais mieux que
ça se déroule comme ça parce que au
moins on pourrait le piloter et surtout
faire en sorte qu'il soit qui soit qui
soit constructif
très bien donc nous allons vous reposer
les questions
et vous aurez la possibilité de répondre
à chacune d'entre elles très bien merci
[Musique]
il vaut mieux à mon avis que vous le
dirigiez et moi je vous répondrai avec
beaucoup de j'espère de partout nous
allons les reprendre
nos problèmes
merci
Monsieur blanc d'abord merci de vous
être rendus disponible dans le cadre des
travaux de cette commission donc comme
ça a été rappelé par la madame la
Présidente notre commission travaille
donc sur les défaillances au sein des
fédérations elles peuvent être tordre
multiples cela a été rappelé alors vous
en tant que champion du monde puis
sélectionneur de l'équipe de France vous
avez eu à connaître de près le
fonctionnement de l'AFF donc première
question en ce qui me concerne en tant
que sélectionneur pouvez-vous nous
relater les relations que vous avez pu
avoir avec la Fédération quels sont les
relations du sélectionneur avec les
équipes de la Fédée avec qui
travaillez-vous DTN Clairefontaine en du
commerce etc je sais si vous pouvez nous
préciser cela
oui alors je vais vous le préciser avec
j'espère beaucoup de précisions le
sélectionneur c'est pas la personne qui
a le plus de contact avec sa fédération
ça peut paraître paradoxal mais
un sélectionneur est vraiment utilisé et
en contact avec des gens qui travaillent
avec fédération ou la BPM la direction
de nationale bien sûr mais le
sélectionneur est un voyage ou en
repérage pendant beaucoup de temps dans
l'année et pendant les matchs
qualificatifs ou les matchs amicaux
c'est là où ils se retrouvent en contact
avec des gens de la BPM notamment est
basé bien sûr à Clairefontaine
en tant que sélectionneur oui nous
allons nous allons faire quelques
réunions à la Fédération Française de
Football les échanges sont
sont sont présents mais mais c'est pas
c'est pas un lieu où le sélectionneur a
l'habitude à l'habitude de séjourner et
séjourne beaucoup plus à la Direction
Technique Nationale et et ça c'est la
première des choses donc la vie la vie
de la Fédération
française de football par exemple parce
que je prends le cas de football c'est
pas un sélectionneur qui pourrait vous
la raconter le mieux qui pourrait
vouloir raconter précisément il y a des
gens qui travaillent à la Fédération
française de football il y a des gens
qui sont l'un des services notamment
marketing
etc qui seraient plus à même à mon avis
de vous raconter la vie de tous les
jours à la Fédération française de
football
après quand je vois la je pose je pose
un petit peu mes yeux sur la première
question et je vous la dit
et on peut en débattre si vous le si
vous le voulez si ça vous intéresse
avez-vous vu le football français
changer au cours de toutes ces années
sur les questions qui nous intéressent
aujourd'hui
j'ai j'ai
envie de vous dire oui il n'a pas changé
le football en lui-même n'a pas changé
le football en lui-même a évolué comme
comme la société comme plein de choses
je pense que le football est un sport
très populaire comme vous le savez
je pense que
même si on est en train de discuter des
déficiences de gestion de gouvernance je
pense que le sport en général le
football en particulier est quand même
utile pour nos pour nos jeunes pour
notre pour notre jeunesse parce que ça
permet de d'abord de prendre conscience
de que le sport est utile dans la vie et
que ça peut devenir un métier que il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes Français de
jeunes de jeunes tout court qui ont
envie de de faire du sport leur métier
donc
oui ça évolué c'est en train de de
ressembler aussi à l'évolution de la de
la société j'ai l'habitude de dire et je
le confirme que le football n'est pas
n'est pas n'est pas en dehors de
l'évolution de la société le football
ressemble à l'évolution de la société
donc si la société évolue dans un
certain milieu ou évolue vers une
certaine direction le football ira dans
cette direction là et et ni dérog era
pas malheureusement puisqu'on en
reviendra après sur les propos que j'ai
pu tenir sur la direction que le
football était en train de prendre et
qui est et qu'il a pris d'ailleurs et
que et que et que c'est ainsi c'est
ainsi fait le football résume
l'évolution de notre société
après si vous avez d'autres questions on
peut débattre on peut échanger il y a
pas de souci
merci beaucoup alors je vais juste
revenir un petit peu sur ma question
parce que en fait moi ce qui m'intéresse
vraiment c'est je parle pas forcément de
la vie de la fédé ou quoi que ce soit je
parle vraiment de du sélectionneur dont
vous attributions à vous
voilà le vis-à-vis de la DTN de la
présidence
quels sont finalement les ces relations
pas forcément de la vie de la fédération
j'avais pas forcément compris cela alors
oui il échange avec la DTN est très
importante le sélectionneur comme je le
savais
et là pour sélectionner mais mais mais
on a une relation beaucoup à mon avis
beaucoup plus importante et beaucoup
plus étroite avec la Btn la direction
nationale qu'avec la fédération en
elle-même ou effectivement on peut avoir
des échanges avec son président on peut
avoir des échanges avec son service
commercial ou son service marketing
parce que des fois il y a des sujets à
traiter mais non la direction technique
nationale
[Musique]
est très important il y a des échanges
assez permanents mais j'en veux pour
preuve moi je vais vous raconter un
petit peu une anecdote c'est que et elle
est très Sims significative c'est que
j'avais une très très bonne relation
avec avec le DTN de l'époque et donc par
là on est chargé beaucoup sur le sur
l'évolution sur le monde le monde de
détection le monde de sélection des
jeunes
mais il n'empêche que pendant deux ans
je n'ai assisté qu'une fois une réunion
de la DTN qui a eu lieu dans les locaux
justement de la Fédération Française de
Football et et et et voilà donc
d'ailleurs c'était très mal passé parce
que à la suite de cette réunion il y
avait eu ces prémics sur les sur les
binationaux et donc ça m'avait plutôt
porté préjudice mais voilà pour vous
dire que un sélectionneur
c'est pas qu'il n'est pas qu'il est seul
mais il échange avec sa direction
nationale avec son directeur
d'animational il échange aussi bien sûr
avec sa direction
mais bon il est quand même assez seul il
est quand même assez seul le direct
de sélectionneur parce que c'est lui
c'est lui-même qui compose sa sélection
c'est lui-même qui fait ses choix
et après on peut il peut en discuter ça
m'est arrivé d'en discuter avec avec
François Blaquart qui était à l'époque
le directeur technique national avec
monsieur legright qui était Président de
la Fédération française de football on
discutait de nos choix mais le
sélectionneur a quand même à mon avis et
heureusement un pouvoir de sélection de
pouvoir de choix qui est qui est
vraiment
très individuel
donc il y a des échanges certes
après sincèrement le monde de
gouvernance de la Fédération française
de football
puisque je vois que c'est aussi écrit
dans une des questions qui ne sont
proposées on peut en discuter parce que
bon tout le monde peut avoir son avis
je vois que la Fédération Française de
Football dépend de l'ordre public
excusez-moi excusez-moi juste avant de
passer effectivement aux autres
questions vous inquiétez pas on va on va
y venir est-ce que vous pouvez juste me
parce que vous avez pas répondu sur le
Comex est-ce que vous avez été amené
vous-même à participer à des Comex
la réponse peut être très claire jamais
merci
puisque vous avez quelques questions un
sujet aussi qui nous préoccupe et
notamment dans dans le football
êtes-vous favorable à l'arrêt des matchs
en cas de propos racistes
oui
est-ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé
alors là aussi
je reconnais que on est dans une période
où
il y a un grand intérêt sur ces
questions et
j'en suis le premier convaincu qu'il
faut qu'il faut essayer par tous les
moyens d'arrêter d'arrêter cela et c'est
pour ça que je vous réponds sans aucune
hésitation oui
mais j'aimerais quand même un petit peu
parce que la dernière fois avec
Guillaume on avait aussi une réunion sur
sur les débats de ces sujets là sur le
racisme sur
l'homophobie etc etc et je me permets de
de faire en sorte que le football n'est
pas parfait loin de là loin de là mais
je pense qu'il évolue dans le bon sens
vous allez peut-être être surpris de mes
propos mais
je suis allé voir des matchs de football
avec mon grand-père je suis allé voir
des matchs de football avec mon père
et j'étais j'étais jeune très jeune mais
il y a des choses qui m'ont marqué alors
il y a des gens des choses qui m'ont
marqué sur le terrain bien sûr mais à
cette époque là c'est quand même pas si
loin que ça
c'était à tous les matchs qui avait des
des
choses à remarquer des choses à éliminer
et je pense que 25 ans ou 30 ans plus
tard même si tout n'est pas parfait et
je le conçois surtout dans une enceinte
comme un stade de football qui est quand
même très grande et où il y a quasiment
toute la liberté d'expression possible
je pense qu'on est en train d'évoluer du
bon côté parce que effectivement ça
existe encore mais par rapport à ce qui
se faisait avant
il y a beaucoup de mieux ça c'est que
mon avis mais ça n'engage que moi et
j'ai pour ça que je vous dis entre
joueurs s'il y a des propos racistes il
faut arrêter à mon avis
net le match
et s'il y a des propos aussi dans
l'enceinte du stade il faudrait aussi le
faire la même chose
on a des moyens maintenant
qui sont colossaux pour pour entendre
pour visualiser pour localiser
alors ça sera très très bien pour le
football
professionnel il n'empêche que dans le
football amateur il m'arrive encore
d'aller voir des matchs et Marie aussi
d'entendre encore des choses des choses
ingrates
mais ça c'est l'éducation qu'il faudra
que comme progressera et que on évoluera
sur le dans le bon sens je sais pas si
ça a été le cas durant ces 20 dernières
ou 25 dernières années
alors on entend tout à fait ce que vous
nous dites sur le football qui qui irait
dans le bon sens mais en fait ça vient
exactement à l'inverse des propos tenus
par Patrick Vieira notamment qui lui dit
sur le racisme ce qui me fait réfléchir
le plus dernièrement c'est qu'on est
passé des cris venus des tribunes à des
agissements de joueurs voire d'arbitre
c'est en train de se dégrader donc on
voit bien que voilà il y a des peut-être
des avis effectivement qui sont très
différents des points de vue qui sont
très différents aussi et lui pour lui en
tout cas il estime qu'il y a une
dégradation et j'en profite aussi parce
que je trouve
que c'est une amélioration parce que
quand vous entendez ces propos là vous
pouvez vous pouvez les
visualiser vous pouvez intervenir
sur des joueurs ou sur des arbitres
alors qu'avant c'était c'était sur 20
000 pièces
comment vous faisiez comment vous
comment vous pourriez faire pour essayer
de
d'exercer d'exercer une punition à ces
gens-là
je dis que l'évolution il y a une
évolution qui me paraît être
non acceptable certes mais qui peut être
qui peut être visualisé qui peut être
corrigé alors
le plus jeune que moi mais il y avait 25
ans je peux vous dire que dans le dans
le dans le football dans le football à
25 ans ou enfin je sais pas si vous
pouvez le vérifier mais il y a le décrit
il y avait des des gestes il y avait des
objets il y a il y avait de tout
donc c'est pour ça que je dis qu'on est
en train d'évoluer à mon avis dans le
bon sens même si tout n'est pas passé je
le conçois mais il y avait 25 ans dans
les stades de football même si
aujourd'hui c'est un lieu où il y a
beaucoup de liberté d'expression
notamment dans un stade de football mais
avant il y avait une liberté
d'expression une liberté d'agir qui
faisait que bon du début jusqu'à la fin
il y avait des choses inacceptables
alors peut-être effectivement qu'on le
voit plus et je sais pas si ça va dans
le bon sens ou pas ce qui est certain
c'est que ce qui revient comme
globalement c'est qu'il y a très peu de
sanctions qui sont prises peu
d'accompagnement des sportifs lorsqu'ils
sont victimes de propos ou de faire
racistes et donc en réalité même si
c'est visible ça veut pas dire que on a
mis en place des outils en tout cas des
solutions pour faire en sorte que cela
ne se reproduise plus c'est l'une des
difficultés justement et l'une des
failles qu'on appuie identifier et en
fait moi je voulais justement par
rapport à cela l'an passé en fait la FFF
a vu de nouvelles accusations notamment
sur des abus de Clairefontaine dans une
enquête publiée sur le site josimar est
reprise par le New York Times et
intitulé 40 ans de silence on y apprend
que pendant des années Noël le Grete et
d'autres aux responsables de la
fédération ont dissimulé de multiples
cas d'abus sexuels y compris des abuses
sur des joueurs mineurs
comment moi comment avez-vous appris ces
faits de votre côté qu'en avez-vous
pensé en tant que sélectionneur à
l'époque c'était début 2012 je rappelle
qu'un des cas pour exemple impliquer un
responsable pédagogique qui a été démi
de son poste à l'Institut national du
football après avoir envoyé des dizaines
de SMS affectueux voire dérangeant un
garçon de 13 ans un comportement
inapproprié de l'encadrant qui aurait
été suivi d'une invitation à déjeuner
pour l'anniversaire du mineur alors que
celui-ci était censé se restaurer à la
cantine de son collège et la FFF a
toléré que cet ancien employé passe
tranquillement d'un poste à l'autre et
conserve ses diplômes qui lui facilitent
l'accès à différents emplois au sein de
ce sport j'aimerais vraiment vous
entendre là dessus
mais je suis comme vous je suis horrifié
de ça mais
Messieurs messieurs les politiques
que la fédération est quand même sous
ordre public à un moment donné il faut
il faut aussi pouvoir faire un sort et
agir et agir pour essayer de de
faire en sorte que ces problèmes là
[Musique]
soient moins fréquents d'abord
soit aussi connu parce que je suppose
que
et c'est aussi un dessin qui me fait
dire que malheureusement même si les
choses ne sont pas parfaites on évolue
aussi parce que les choses commencent à
se savoir et alors qu'avant peut-être le
savait pas où on les disait pas où on
les ou on les connaissait pas où on
voulait pas les connaître donc voilà il
y a quand même des axes qui font que bon
voilà je dis pas que les progrès sont
spectaculaires mais je dis qu'il y a des
certainement des choses aujourd'hui que
l'on connaît qu'on est informé alors que
il y a certainement des périodes où on
n'avait pas ces informations et quand
vous me dites vous qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez j'aurais tendance à vous dire
mais vous qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
vous
vous êtes certainement horrifié comme
moi non bien évidemment c'est d'ailleurs
pour aussi l'objet de cette commission
d'enquête mais voilà mais c'est pour ça
que j'ai répondu avec avec plaisir avec
vous parce que je pense que comme vous
dites et vous le pensionné souvent que
la Fédération Française de Football est
quand même sous tutelle sous tutelle de
de de de l'orthophonie
et un moment donné il faut il faut il
faut il faut essayer de trouver des
solutions aussi en termes de gouvernance
en termes peut-être de de de
d'hommes parce que c'est aussi c'est
aussi ça de faire en sorte que ce qui a
pu se passer dans les
il y a quelques années ne se repassent
ne se reproduisent plus que ce soit dans
la Fédération française de football ou
que dans que ce soit dans le sport en
général parce que j'ai aussi écouté
d'autres d'autres
personnes qui sont intervenues devant
votre commission et notamment une jeune
fille
oui c'est oui la réalité c'est son
discours et
son discours aujourd'hui a touché
énormément de monde est-ce que est-ce
que est-ce qu'il y a quelques années ça
aurait pu être le cas je sais pas moi je
suis de ceux qui pensent que voilà
aujourd'hui on est au courant de plein
de choses alors on ne l'était pas quand
vous n'êtes pas au courant
c'est difficile de les régler ou de les
corriger là il s'avère que dans l'heure
actuelle ou dans les dans le présent que
l'on vit on est au courant des choses à
un moment donné il faut essayer de vous
comme moi de faire en sorte que que les
choses ont les corrige
on les corrige avez-vous la connaissance
de la cellule du ministère des Sports
signal sport
je ne connais je m'appelle je sais pas
si une commission c'est
c'est
je c'est la première fois que j'entends
parler de signal sport
je suppose que ce que ça veut dire mais
c'est une bonne chose bien sûr c'est une
bonne chose
les choses se diront ce seront et puis
on aura tendance à corriger mais
je pense comme vous le savez comme on le
sait tous qu'il y a certaines choses qui
se sont passées et qui sont et qui se
passeront aussi parce qu'on arrivera pas
du jour au lendemain
faire en sorte de régler tous les
problèmes mais essayons de faire en
sorte de d'avoir des
vigilants c'est des des actions de de de
pour prévenir tout cela quoi voilà
et avez-vous l'impression que la parole
se libère davantage
oui c'est une pour moi pour moi ça
n'engage que moi c'est une certitude
alors je reconnais que c'est difficile
parce que j'ai vu cette personne là
devant cette commission seul en train de
parler en train de revivre certaines
choses qui étaient très douloureux
certainement pour elle pour ne pas en
dire plus
et ça m'a ça m'a touché quoi ça m'a
touché
et voilà
c'est une c'est une c'est une c'est une
épreuve une épreuve pour la pour la
pour la pour la péniante et puis et puis
voilà c'est
mais en même temps c'est une je pense
comme elle le l'a dit c'est une
délivrance pour elle mais il faudrait
arriver à me faire en sorte qu'il y ait
des comment on appelle ça des feux de de
prévention pour essayer de
d'éviter ce genre de choses même si ça
se passe il faut pas aussi ce ce
focaliser que dans le sport ça se passe
aussi malheureusement de partout
il y avait vous la parole l'impression
que cette parole est entendue notamment
au plus haut niveau
la parole de la jeune de la jeune femme
ou la parole de témoignage des victimes
quelle qu'elle soit
le problème c'est que quand vous
entendez une victime son témoignage j'ai
toujours bouleversant malheureusement ça
s'est passé
je sais pas dans des
dans des endroits alors
moi c'est pas moi décidé les endroits
risques mais en ce qui concerne le sport
les entraînements des adolescents des
adolescentes etc etc il y a bien sûr des
des
entraîneurs ou des éducateurs qui sont
là qui sont là pour les éduquer pour les
entraîner pour les amener au meilleur
niveau pour représenter notre pays aussi
donc voilà comment faire ces échanges
seront là seront toujours présents mais
il faudrait avoir des avertisseurs je
sais pas comment on appelle ça mais
voilà
quand il y a des relations
adolescentes adolescentes adultes mais
c'est très bien malheureusement que
qu'on n'est pas à l'abri de ce genre de
choses
on va laisser la parole à notre collègue
François Piquemal
oui bonjour monsieur blanc François
Piquemal député de Haute-Garonne tout
d'abord vous remercier de votre
participation à cette audition et de vos
réponses moi j'aimerais revenir sur la
question d'ailleurs que vous avez évoqué
de la réunion qui s'est tenue à la FFF
en 2010 en novembre 2010 et qui avait
fait grand bruit qu'on avait appelé
réunion des quotas ou autre
dans cette réunion il y a eu des propos
qui ont qui ont blessé un certain nombre
de personnes parce que donc il y avait
une discussion sur la sélection des
jeunes joueurs et est arrivé est arrivé
dans cette discussion on va dire des
préjugés ou des caractéristiques qui
étaient attribuées aux joueurs selon
leur couleur de peau c'est ce qu'on en
comprenait c'est à dire en gros qu'il
fallait davantage vos vos vos vos vos
vous me préciserez davantage en tout cas
selon ce qu'avait dit Monsieur
montbaerts
sélectionnez des joueurs petits
techniques intelligents dans le jeu et
ils le disait blanc voilà au contraire
des joueurs noirs qui auquel il était
toujours rapporté qu'ils étaient
athlétiques mais mais sous-entendu un
petit peu dénué d'intelligence dans le
jeu ce qui forcément
prête des caractéristiques selon la
couleur de peau et peut être vécu comme
raciste ou comme tout le cas des des
quotas discriminatoires et des joueurs
s'en étaient émus autant que des
personnalités diverses et variées moi
j'aimerais savoir et Francis se Smerecki
qui est assisté à la réunion à l'époque
et avait alerté sur le fait que ce genre
de pratique était discriminatoire moi
j'aimerais savoir avec le recul de plus
de 10 années après cette réunion
quel bilan
vous vous en tirez est-ce que vous
souvenez du contexte de cette réunion
comment cette discussion est arrivée et
ce que vous regrettez aujourd'hui d'être
entré un petit peu dans ces éléments-là
et comment vous expliquer qu'on est plus
en arriver à avoir ce genre de réflexion
qui si elle ne caractérise pas du
racisme direct profond comme cela
peuvent être vu comme tel au regard des
propos tenus
alors juste peut-être excusez-moi juste
peut-être avant de vous laisser répondre
c'est Madame s'éveille la rapporteur
puisque j'aimerais vraiment compléter la
question autour de cette affaire dite
des quotas parce que la réalité c'est
qu'on cherche un peu aussi à faire la
lumière sur ce qui a pu mener à ces
réflexions puisqu'on sait un corps il y
a quelques mois de cela nous avons une
autre affaire de ce type là dans un
autre club de foot donc on voit bien que
depuis 2011 ça n'a pas vraiment évolué
et que c'est pratique visiblement se
font encore dans certains clubs donc
d'abord peut-être moi ma première
question là dessus serait d'abord
pourriez-vous nous expliquer le contexte
de cette réunion ensuite une question je
connais pas je ne connais pas bien le
fonctionnement mais est-il courant que
le sélectionneur national s'implique
dans les questions de formation et de
jeunes et bien il m'avait semblé que
c'était pas dans les attributions voilà
déjà pour commencer juste ces questions
merci non pas du tout c'est pour ça que
je vais être très clair avec vous et
alors c'est pas que ça me fait plaisir
d'éclaircir tout ça mais ce qui met ce
qui me désole aussi c'est que on en
reparle que 12 ans après quoi donc
sincèrement j'ai l'impression que bon il
y a juste réunion il y a eu des
amalgames qui ont été faits il y a eu
des des mots qui ont été dit et puis
j'ai l'impression que voilà ça s'est
étouffé qu'on a qu'on a qu'on a pas
voulu en reparler on en reparle
effectivement parce que je vois que ça
vous intéresse beaucoup cette réunion là
donc on en reparle 12 ans après et vous
allez être d'accord avec moi que pendant
12 ans
rien rien il s'est pas passé grand chose
c'est pas passé grand chose donc la
réunion je voulais dire je voulais
confirmer tout à l'heure c'est que
c'était pas dans les attributions de
d'être dans les réunions de la DTM pas
du tout donc on m'avait invité sur cette
réunion là parce que je pense qu'il y
avait des gens qui qui avaient déjà des
intentions des mauvaises intentions et
je pense que voilà on m'avait on m'avait
on m'avait on m'avait convoqué dans
cette réunion là et j'avais répondu
présent parce que j'estimais que
effectivement ça pourrait être
intéressant des échanges avec des
entraîneurs nationaux sont toujours
intéressants
parce que je pensais qu'on avait
vraiment parlé football développement
etc etc il s'avère que la Réunion durant
qui a duré une heure et demie 90 minutes
pendant 85 minutes on a parlé de
effectivement d'échange de sélection etc
je vous le dis il faut sincèrement
c'était la dernière question nous dit
bon ben voilà on a fait on a fait quand
même quelques quelques recherches et que
et que sur le pourcentage de tous les
joueurs qui sortent de la DTN on est
assez content parce que on arrive quand
même à
sortir
un pourcentage très élevé internationaux
internationaux et donc donc on déballe
dessus et je sais plus si c'est Francis
perçonnable qui nous dit bon et on est
allé quand même on a quand même poussé
plus l'analyse en disant que voilà il y
avait il y avait il y avait un
pourcentage très élevé aussi
d'internationaux étrangers
donc et c'est là où je vous dis mais je
l'ai toujours dit alors peut-être je me
suis mal expliqué que moi j'étais
intervenu justement parce que je bougame
parler parce que c'est une question qui
même aujourd'hui même aujourd'hui est
encore à l'ordre du jour c'est que
c'était la question des données
nationaux
et donc et donc c'est posé la question
on en a débattu et c'est là où le
monsieur il y a une question qui
avait certainement gros sur la patate
a mis son interphone en marche et nous a
enregistré donc la ville différent mais
on pouvait en discuter et c'est comme ça
que c'était cette réunion est devenue
est devenue
la chose principale ou le titre
d'information principale pendant 15
jours ou trois semaines donc voilà tout
simplement mais comme je vous dis le
sélectionneur et à ceux qui me concerne
je suis resté deux ans sélectionné
j'ai répondu une fois l'invitation de la
de la réunion de de la DTN qui me
paraissait intéressante qui a été
intéressante mais qui sur une question à
la fin a été très très mal vécu par mois
et par d'autres parce qu'il y a eu des
amalgames de fées il y a eu des
accusations de fait qui font que bon ça
a été assez insupportable après
donc voilà
voilà vraiment ce qui s'est passé et
quand je vois quand je vois alors ça ça
devait être en 2011 2011 ou 2010 je sais
plus et quand je vois en 2023 ce qui a
été fait ou ce qui a été
fait je me dis que rien n'a été fait
rien rien
n'a été fait donc c'est bien peut-être
de le de le
remettre
au goût du jour si j'ose dire mais
sincèrement
en termes de d'action en termes de
discussion après cette réunion là qui a
été qui a été malheureusement
très célèbre rien n'a été fait rien n'a
été fait que ce soit au niveau sportif
au niveau politique il faut le dire
le sujet est toujours présent et il y a
pas de réponse
donc bon voilà après chacun peut avoir
son opinion mais
j'ai mon opinion en tant que citoyen
simple citoyen après
je pense que les choses qui peuvent être
améliorées ou qui peuvent évolués il y a
que il y a qu'une volonté une volonté
[Musique]
alors j'entends complètement ce que ce
que vous dites mais après pour moi c'est
pas tellement une question
d'interprétation parce que y compris
enfin moi je sais pas si vous si on
comprend les mois finalement des
personnes quand on entend parler de
joueurs black par exemple on est bien
au-delà de la question de la
binationalité on est vraiment sur des
critères là de couleur de peau là la
commission d'enquête justement travaille
là-dessus et vous l'avez dit et je suis
je suis triste de l'entendre
qu'effectivement depuis cette affaire
rien n'a changé et d'ailleurs j'évoquais
depuis tout à l'heure la faire Galtier
on est quasiment sur la même chose et
c'était il y a un an donc on voit bien
que les choses pas forcément changé mais
surtout ce que je veux dire c'est que on
parle là d'une réunion à l'époque qui
évite qui évoque une limitation de
joueurs d'apparence ou d'origine noir ou
arabe
donc en fait c'est pour ça que moi je
vous dis ce que vous comprenez les mois
c'est pas tellement une question
d'interprétation pour moi c'est voilà on
est au-delà de cela quand on parle de
limiter des joueurs parce qu'ils sont
noirs ou arabes dans une équipe ou dans
une sélection je pense que c'est
difficile de laisser le doute à
l'interprétation
je suis d'accord avec vous Madame mais
sincèrement le sujet moi qui m'avait qui
m'avait qui m'avait intéressé d'abord
c'était nationaux
les quotas de joueurs c'était un sujet
qui avait été développé par la DPN parce
qu'ils avaient fait des ils avaient fait
des avaient fait des enquêtes et ils
avaient fait des enfin pas des sondages
mais au niveau de la formation notamment
dans la dans la Ligue de Paris
et donc ils en étaient arrivés à
certaines conclusions mais moi le
sélectionneur que j'ai pété à l'époque
était intervenu notamment sur les
binationaux et je vois que le sujet est
encore présent très présent encore
aujourd'hui quand vous dit bon vous
savez madame dans je suis je suis je
suis entraîneur je suis dans la rue je
suis dans les dans les dans les
vestiaires
je peux vous dire que voilà il y a des
mots qui fusent certainement dans les
vestiaires et que si vous prenez que les
mots si vous prenez exactement le mot
qui fuse de parler joueur d'ailleurs par
les joueurs eux-mêmes
les termes que vous venez d'employer on
les entend on les entend à longueur de
journée
François picnin
oui
je pense qu'on rejoint votre constat sur
le fait que cette réunion a lieu il y a
plus de 10 ans et que on a la sensation
que rien n'a été fait ou en tout cas
mais bon ce qui avait choqué je pense
c'est un petit peu ému lors de cette
réunion c'est que vous avez raison des
des mots on peut les entendre dans des
vestiaires mais là c'était une réunion
de la Fédération française de football
avec parmi lesquels ces principaux
représentants ou dirigeants donc
forcément ça ça avait écrit un émoi moi
ma question c'était pas de c'était pas
de refaire le match de cette réunion il
a il a été fait sans sans que des
centres des conséquences politiques ne
suivent et c'est ça qui est très
dommageable et c'est aussi l'objet de
cette mission d'information mais c'est
de savoir vous parce que Eric mon Bart
dans cette réunion disait mais ça existe
déjà dans les clubs d'avoir des quotas
et on voit là on a un exemple de comment
une politique
discriminatoire insidieuse peut être
mise en place officiellement
officieusement et je vous laisse savoir
si vous en tant qu'entraîneur dans le
milieu professionnel de très haut niveau
vous aviez été témoin ou entendu des cas
de discrimination de toutes sortes qui
se mettait en place de manière
insigneuse
honnêtement non mais si vous prenez les
règles d'aujourd'hui
même avec la loi boseman qui a
révolutionné qui a complètement fait
évolué le football en terme
financier en termes en termes d'humains
de transfert etc etc aujourd'hui les
règles sont tristes sont très claires
vous avez le droit d'avoir
autant d'Européens que vous avez que
vous voulez et par contre vous avez le
droit qu'à
5 extra communautaire
comment vous appelez ça vous
[Musique]
à son avis là-dessus il s'avère il
s'avère qu'un moment donné il y a des
choix à faire il y a des choix à faire
que ce soit pour sa nationalité tout
court pour sa nationalité sportive il
faudrait aider je dis bien aider
les choix à faire à des jeunes souvent
qui ont 18 ans 19 ans 20 ans et qui sont
soumis croyez moi la dépression
à dépression pour pour choisir leur
nationalité sportive je trouve que on
devrait plutôt les aider à faire un
choix
qui est leur choix leur propre choix et
à ce moment-là je pense qu'on est
en forêt évoluer les choses alors que là
on est exactement dans la même
configuration qu'il y a 15 ans 20 ans ou
25 ans
rien n'a changé
pour moi
n'engagement oui alors peut-être juste
je vais revenir juste un petit peu en
arrière sur des une phrase que vous avez
que vous avez dites quand j'ai parlé de
la question des fédérations qui étaient
informés de certains faits notamment de
fêtes violence vous avez évoqué le fait
que même si les fédérations étaient au
courant et on le dit c'est vrai non la
répété à plusieurs reprises c'est une
délégation de service public il y a des
subventions il y a de l'argent public
dans ce mouvement sportif et vous avez
vous avez dit il y a une instance
supérieure qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait donc
moi j'aimerais juste que vous précisiez
de qui vous parlez exactement est-ce que
c'est le ministère des Sports est-ce que
c'est le politique est-ce que c'est
voilà de qui on parle exactement
suivi quand je dis qu'une fédération et
vous la vérité vous venez de le dire
encore une fois
elle est elle est elle est elle est
elle est
d'utilité publique elle est alors je
sais pas si c'est le le mot employé mais
surveiller ou chaperoné par le ministère
des Sports
puisque c'est une délégation une
délégation la Fédération française vous
êtes en train de me dire que
comment on fait pour pour pour
améliorer les choses sincèrement en tant
que citoyen que simple citoyen
j'ai pas la réponse j'ai pas la réponse
j'ai quelques idées comme toutes les
citoyens mais je pense que bon déjà pour
essayer de trouver des réponses il
faudrait il faudrait être conscient du
problème être au courant du problème et
vouloir régler le problème ou vouloir
améliorer
corriger certaines choses enfin je sais
pas je
réfléchis basiquement mais il me semble
que c'est ce que je ferai ou c'est ce
que j'essayerai de faire voilà
une question à notre collègue Stéphane
Bichou
merci madame la Présidente bonjour
monsieur blanc Stéphane Buchoud député
de vente
enchanté
je veux revenir sur sur désolé mais je
vais revenir sur la réunion de novembre
vous faites le constat comme d'autres
que depuis 2010 rien n'a changé
alors effectivement lors de cette
réunion
[Musique]
il y a la question des binationaux il y
a aussi la question des quotas sur des
critères physiques liés
à la couleur de peau liée à la race
je précise que c'était une c'était une
une
c'est pas une enquête oui c'était une
enquête que la
la BTM directionnelle avait fait donc ça
est-ce qu'elle avait été missionné pour
le faire j'en sais rien je peux pas
sincèrement c'est pas pardon
j'entends
c'est pas le sens de ma question le sens
de la question vous étiez sélectionneur
de l'équipe de France à l'époque oui moi
j'ai une question assez simple des
propos on a des propos en tant que on
enquêtait tenu ils ont été par la suite
documentés je voulais savoir si en tant
que sélectionneur en tant que citoyen
les propos qui avaient été tenus à
l'époque vous ont choquez ma première
question et ma deuxième question
vous faites le constat et je pense qu'on
le fait tous malheureusement je le
répète que rien n'a changé depuis
maintenant 12 ans ne pensez-vous pas
justement que
une des raisons pour lesquelles rien ne
rien ne change ou peut changer c'est
justement le fait que suite à des propos
qui étaient choquants
les choses ont été plus ou moins
étouffées il n'y a-t-il pas une forme
d'institutionnalisation de propos que
l'on peut quand même qualifier de
raciste vous disiez tout à l'heure
que vous n'aviez que peu de solutions à
proposer pour que les choses évoluent
moi j'ai envie de vous renvoyer le
ballon pardonnez-moi pour l'image mais
on a
qu'est-ce que vous avez pu constater
vous au sein de la fédération est-ce que
vous avez constaté des
dysfonctionnements qui font que ce genre
d'affaires
au final n'ont aucune conséquence parce
que c'est quand même ça là c'est quand
même ça la situation c'est que 12 ans
après on reparle de cette fameuse
réunion de novembre 2010 le collègue
François final a très bien rappelé les
choses mais mais on a le sentiment en
fait que
c'était pas si grave que ça et que ça
pourrait recommencer aujourd'hui et que
personne n'en attirait les conséquences
et c'est un peu ça si vous voulez que je
trouve moi choquant on est au sein d'une
commission d'enquête moi je ne jette le
propre sur personne je te fais de procès
à personne mais simplement l'objectif de
notre commission d'enquête c'est quand
même de mettre fin à la fois à des faits
de violence sur les enfants et à des
propos discriminants et souvent racistes
et si chacun si chacun dit bah au final
ça se passe mais on peut rien faire
c'est quand même totalement désespérant
et je pense que le politique le
politique peut beaucoup mais le
politique ne peut pas seul et donc on a
besoin effectivement
de gens qui ont vécu des choses en
particulier quand on a votre
carrière votre notoriété je pense
vraiment qu'on a besoin envie de vous
entendre sur votre vécu est-ce que vous
pourriez nous apporter comme comme
solution parce que vous le dites vous
êtes au quotidien
dans les vestiaires etc mais je ne pense
pas que des propos tenus dans un
vestiaires et des propos tenus lors
d'une réunion de la Fédération française
de football avec les plus hautes
instances soit à mettre sur le même plan
et Monsieur votre discours est tout à
fait tout à fait tout à fait
positive tout à fait acceptable mais on
est en train de on est en train de vous
vous êtes en train de dire voilà sans
les hommes de terrain sur le terrain ou
au contact de 1 on y arrivera pas et moi
je suis en train de vous dire que si
l'autorité que vous pouvez représenter
dans ce cas là
sans vous on y arrivera pas non plus
donc là on est en train de en train de
de se renvoyer un petit peu les
les responsabilités mais je pense que
oui effectivement tous les deux nous
avons
les deux parties ont des choses à
améliorer mais permettez-moi de penser
que en termes de
[Musique]
capacité ou de d'efficacité il me semble
que vous avez pas vous personnellement
mais
le ministère ou la
l'autorité l'autorité publique a quand
même le droit et le devoir
de vérifier de vérifier certaines choses
de sa fédération son fonctionnement
son président son sa manière de présider
etc etc donc vous avez quand même des
pouvoirs que que les gens peut-être de
terrain n'ont quand même pas
c'est une question que je me pose mais
je pense savoir la réponse
donc voilà donc
pourquoi vous êtes en train de me dire
bah ça fait 12 ans que rien ne s'est
passé moi
c'est la première fois en 12 ans que je
suis appelé à
parler avec avec une commission et je le
fais avec grand plaisir je vous le dis
franchement je le fais avec grand
plaisir mais c'est la première fois
qu'on me voit que demain une commission
ni depuis 2010 ou depuis 2011 on n'a
jamais convoqué à qui que ce soit si
deux convocation ministère pour des
entretiens privés mais ça s'arrête là ça
s'arrêtait
donc
je sur cette question là
on a fait certainement pas assez ni les
hommes de terrain
que je pense que les gens qui ont
l'autorité de pouvoir peut-être faire
changer les choses n'en font pas assez
suffisamment à mon avis alors justement
puisque on évoque la question de
l'autorité au moment de cette fameuse
réunion finalement je pense que je pense
que la Réunion vous permettez je vais
terminer la question et puis après je
vous laisserai répondre avec plaisir
sans aucun souci lors de cette réunion
en réalité
moi ce qui me questionne c'est que
finalement les propos qui ont été tenus
lors de cette réunion n'ont pas choqué
les personnes qui étaient autour de la
table de cette réunion il a fallu que ça
sorte à l'extérieur dans un média
notamment pour que ça choque l'opinion
publique et qu'il y ait une enquête qui
soit mise en place avec d'ailleurs pas
de sanction derrière donc première
question c'est est-ce que vous ne pensez
pas que le fait qu'il n'y ait pas de
sanction justement favorise le fait que
rien ne change depuis 12 ans et la
deuxième chose c'est vous je termine
juste et vous vous évoquez aussi
beaucoup la question des ministères par
exemple selon vous est-ce que la
Fédération elle-même n'aurait pas pu
proposer des sanctions aux personnes qui
ont tenu ses propos qui sont enfin
légalement réponses quand on parle de
racisme ou de discrimination
oui mais ce que vous oubliez de dire
Madame c'est que cette réunion a été
rendue publique parce qu'il y a un
monsieur qui a mis un interphone sous un
sous un livre alors des réunions
des réunions
à la Fédération Française de Football
voilà DTN ou de partout dans tout dans
tous les dans tous les secteurs
d'activités
industrielles ou sportives des réunions
privées sur 10 ans privés je peux vous
dire et je pense sincèrement qui doit se
tenir qui doit aussi se tenir des propos
qui vous choquerez vous et moi donc ça a
été rendu public n'oublions pas par un
geste quand même qui est à mon avis
n'est pas encouragé ça c'est mon avis
personnel effectivement après une fois
que le problème a été a été connu de
tout oui effectivement la Fédération
Française de Football voir le ministère
de la Jeunesse et Sport aurait dû
auraient dû prendre des décisions aurait
dû prendre des directions et surtout
aurait dû essayer d'améliorer les choses
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
monsieur blanc à nouveau Stéphane Buchot
moi je voulais rebondir sur sur les
propos que vous venez de tenir bon
j'entends que
j'entends qu'il faille que l'autorité
publique comme vous l'appelez
interviennent alors justement qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qu'il aurait fallu qu'il
se passe à l'issue de cette réunion
pour que les choses puissent changer
qu'est-ce que l'autorité publique aurait
dû aurait dû faire
c'est pas un piège je me suis lancé
c'est absolument pas un piège c'est
vraiment pour qu'on puisse c'est
vraiment pas c'est vraiment pour qu'on
puisse avancer et que nous on puisse au
sein du rapport qui va être remis à la
fin de l'année faire des propositions
très concrètes pour que justement ne
plus entendre ce que ce que je viens
d'entendre dans votre bouche c'est à
dire il y a au final beaucoup de
réunions où il y a des propos qui qui
choqueraient tout le monde
il faut éradiquer ça il faut qu'il y a
un moment donné ces propos là ne soient
plus tenus et on a besoin effectivement
de de d'avoir des outils efficaces et
c'est donc le sens de ma vie
ce que j'arrive pas à comprendre c'est
que alors pas vous personnellement
l'autorité
c'est qui qui l'a représenté
dans une dans une dans un cadre de dans
un dans une dans un monde de
fonctionnement de Fédération française
de football par exemple prenons la
Fédération française de football qui a
d'autorité qui a pouvoir
pardon pardon pardon de vous couper mais
je pense je pense déjà dans un premier
temps que le président de la Fédération
Française
constatant un certain nombre de dérives
au sein de sa propre fédération devrait
prendre un certain nombre de mesures à
minima correctives
je suis d'accord je suis d'accord
entièrement d'accord avec vous mais il
me semble que c'était un sujet aussi de
discussion qu'on pourrait avoir là aussi
il y a des il y a des dysfonctionnements
et vous le savez aussi bien que moi
puisque bon c'est d'ordre public aussi
et donc à partir de là tout n'est pas
parfait quoi tout n'est pas parfait
allô oui monsieur blanc c'est de nouveau
François picomal on se répartissait la
parole moi je voulais je voulais aborder
un autre sujet avec vous
vous avez déclaré récemment que le
football prenait une direction qui ne
vous plaisait pas avec beaucoup de
spéculation et
c'est intéressant parce que je pense que
la puissance publique peut aussi avoir
son mot à dire là-dessus parce que vous
dites et c'est je partage totalement on
valorise des joueurs non pas par rapport
à ce qu'ils font sur le terrain mais
vis-à-vis de ce qu'il génère comme
valeur financière on les achète 10
millions d'euros par exemple pour les
revendre 3 ou 4 fois plus cher on a vu
des modèles économiques de certains
clubs êtes basés uniquement là dessus je
vais pas citer deux clubs en particulier
mais tous ceux qui regardent le football
européen ou français sur des cas précis
et qui qui connaissent un peu verront
des calons parle et on assiste à une
finalement
on va jusqu'au bout de la logique du
joueur de football comme produit
financier avant d'être un athlète et
derrière l'athlète un humain comme un
autre et moi je voulais savoir comment
vous aviez vu cette évolution
dans le football parce qu'après tout
vous quand vous jouiez vous êtes parti
aussi en Italie jouer à Naples notamment
puis vous étiez revenu à l'Inter Milan
et déjà on avait quand même
au début des années 90 ses premiers
effets du foot business avec Bernard
Tapie
Berlusconi etc mais qui avait une
logique on va dire davantage de d'avoir
les meilleurs joueurs et d'y mettre le
prix pour gagner des compétitions alors
que là on a vraiment une logique
purement de revente spéculative des
joueurs et ainsi de suite avec la
question de la multipropriété des clubs
vous comment vous avez vu ce tournant se
faire ce que vous l'avez vu
progressivement est-ce qu'il y a eu un
moment assez marquant et surtout est-ce
qu'il y a eu des réflexions au sein de
la fédération peut-être on avait vous
connaissances sur et bien comment la
puissance publique notamment la
Fédération Française de foot pouvait un
petit peu mettre le haut là pratique
monsieur là je suis en plein dedans
puisque l'évolution du football je l'ai
vu je l'ai vu je l'ai vu je l'ai vécu
moi-même
j'ai commencé à jouer au football dans
les années 80 où il y avait pas d'argent
dans le football il y avait très peu
d'argent dans le football et donc
le football a pris cette voie là c'est
les télévisions c'est le marketing des
télévisions notamment qui ont fait en
sorte que l'argent devienne vraiment
très important dans le milieu du sport
et notamment dans le milieu du football
et oui je disais que très récemment que
la direction que prenait le football me
plaisait pas parce qu'on va dans un
football business
et alors d'aujourd'hui on y est on y est
totalement je dois dire que les Français
sont encore appris plus fort que les
autres puisque bon quand je disais on
achète un joueur 10 pour le pour essayer
de le revendre en tout cas 40
étant donné que nous avons une très très
bonne formation
française on est encore mieux puisqu'on
les forme donc il nous coûte quasiment
zéro et on les revend 30 40 50 60 70 80
donc il y a du business il y a du
trading ce qu'on appelle maintenant qui
est venu dans le monde du football on en
parle beaucoup ça
il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont
intéressés par le trading parce que j'ai
connu des joueurs qui ont été vendus
d'une année à l'autre et qui ont été
multipliées par 10 ou par 20 donc c'est
on est vraiment dans le football
business bien sûr l'argent a attiré
beaucoup beaucoup de gens
intéressés
on a pris on n'a pas on a passé
sélectionné on a tout pris et donc quand
j'entends le monsieur qui nous dit la
Fédération aurait pu interdire la
Fédération elle a aucun pouvoir là aucun
pouvoir c'est mon avis ça n'engage que
moi la Fédération subissant
donc
je dis pas oui elle peut avoir son avis
elle peut avoir mais mais en terme de de
pouvoir d'intervention ou de ou de
changer de direction non là à mon avis
c'est de donner des pouvoirs que que les
fédérations n'ont pas
donc là on est on est vraiment en plus
dans le l'outil propriété ce que vous
venez d'évoquer on est en train de de
faire en sorte aussi que certaines pays
certaines régions s'intéressent de plus
en plus au football parce que c'est un
sport universel et que ça ça intéresse
beaucoup beaucoup de gens d'abord et
puis de pays aussi et là on y est
vraiment on est dans le cœur du sujet ou
l'argent est roi
ou les joueurs de football en profitent
bien sûr et
là je sais pas si la Fédération
peut faire quelque chose mais à mon avis
non
donc là c'est pas de son pouvoir la
Fédération n'aura pas ce pouvoir là ni
d'ailleurs ni d'ailleurs
la Fédération Internationale la FIFA ou
l'UEFA
peut-être que la FIFA avec avec son son
grand pouvoir aussi peut essayer de de
tempérer tout ça mais il s'avère que
quand vous le quand vous quand vous le
savez aussi bien que moi le pouvoir
financier est
présent
il est très très difficile de freiner
tout ça et je pense que là en ce moment
il y a personne qui freine personne et
là on est en plein en plein en plein
plein
échange économique
alors
je suis un peu surprise en fait non mais
je suis très surprise de vous entendre
dire que les fédérations n'ont pas de
pouvoir parce que nous ça fait plusieurs
semaines qu'on fait des auditions et on
entend exactement l'inverse le savoir
quels sont toutes puissantes et que
c'est elle qui font la pluie le beau
temps sur plein de sujets notamment sur
moi je suis étonné parce que vous dites
qu'elles peuvent pas changer les
directions donc dans ce cas là si les
conseils d'administration de fédération
ne peuvent rien faire qui qui change les
personnels de direction dans les postes
donc moi je serai très curieuse de le
savoir et
moi je reviens juste un peu avant sur
les sur les différents mécanismes en
tant que en tant que
symbole je parle des fédérations de
manière générale et la Fédération
Française de Football fait partie de
tous les témoignages qu'on a eu jusqu'à
présent d'une des l'une des fédérations
les plus puissantes
aujourd'hui dans notre pays en tout cas
le football
le gère le football français mais le
football mondial est géré par par notre
puissance ah oui mais nous en ce qui
nous concerne on parle on parle du
football français alors vous parlez
peut-être de la question financière
quand vous dit voilà quand
géré par la Fédération Française de
Football bien sûr mais la direction du
football mondial pour l'universel est en
train de prendre une direction que la
Fédération Française de Football si elle
n'est pas d'accord ou si elle a des ça
me semblera très difficile très jolie
bien très difficile voire impossible de
changer quoi que ce soit
d'accord donc là on comprend un peu
mieux avec la précision mais voilà moi
je veux vraiment revenir sur la question
de la Fédération française de football
et de son mode de fonctionnement et
d'ailleurs des dysfonctionnements parce
que l'objet de la commission d'enquête
c'est aussi avant tout celui-ci parce
que je l'ai évoqué tout à l'heure il y a
eu plusieurs affaires ou visiblement la
fédération en tout cas en tant que telle
était informée qu'on a laissé des
entraîneurs changer de club alors qu'ils
pratiquaient la même chose dans d'autres
clubs auprès de jeunes mineurs je parle
notamment de violences sexuelles sur
enfants sur mineur et vous justement en
tant qu' ancien joueur puis
sélectionneur et coach que pensez-vous
des mécanismes pour protéger les jeunes
à Clairefontaine et plus largement dans
les clubs et est-ce que à votre
connaissance est-ce que c'est un sujet
qui revenait régulièrement au sein des
fédérations parce que l'autre versant
des témoignages c'est aussi qu'il y
avait beaucoup d'adultes qui étaient
informés autour de ses enfants autour de
ses mineurs qui subissaient des
violences et que rien n'était dit et
tout était au contraire caché donc
est-ce que c'était un sujet qui revenait
ce que vous vous en aviez entendu parler
honnêtement avec vous quand j'ai été
deux ans sélectionneur ce sujet-là n'est
jamais venu autour de conversation trop
de d'échanges entre entraîneurs entre
sincèrement sincèrement très éducateur
on n'a jamais alors c'était peut-être
pas un sujet qui était facile à évoquer
mais on l'a jamais voté
sincèrement ce sujet là alors c'était
peut-être certainement d'ailleurs sujet
tabou mais mais
pendant deux ans que j'ai été à la
Direction nationale en tant que
sélectionneur je n'ai jamais entendu
parler de de quoi que ce soit qui
pouvait qui pouvait qui pouvait laisser
penser que il allait il avait il avait
des choses qui se passaient etc je vous
le dis franchement en toute vérité
après c'est un problème c'est un
problème ça c'est je peux pas vous
répondre à ce problème là que ce soit le
fonctionnement d'une fédération comment
vous voulez que je vous dise
le fonctionnement d'une fédération le
connais tous vous le connaissez aussi
bien que moi il est fait il est fait de
de de plein de choses il est fait de de
jeunes joueurs de jeunes de jeunes
athlètes de jeunes sportifs qui sont
encadrés par des adultes que ce soit
homme ou femme et ça que soit dans
n'importe quelle discipline que soit le
football soit le tennis que soit la
natation que ce soit l'athlétisme
il y a un modèle éducatif d'éducation
physique mais c'est c'est
le fonctionnement sera toujours comme ça
c'est là où il faut mettre des
commentaires des avertisseurs je sais
pas comment on dit
et que bon voilà
du moment du moment qui a cette cette
validité de
d'enseigner le sport pour que pour que
les athlètes soient les meilleurs
possibles les entraînements se feront
toujours se feront toujours entre un
adulte et un indicateur et des jeunes
après le système le système de
fédération
là aussi je me permets de vous dire
certaines choses puisque
on voit certaines choses qui se sont
produites on voudrait que ça ne
recommence pas on voudrait que ça soit
corrigé on voudrait que ça soit mieux
mieux mieux mieux mieux mieux élaborer
ce moment-là peut-être il y a il y a un
mode de fonctionnement de fédération qui
devrait évoluer aussi ou qui devrait
changer ou qui devrait être autrement
jamais
comme vous le dit comme vous le dit
qu'il faudrait il faudrait changer sur
le sujet avec certainement des personnes
qui ont d'autres qui ont d'autres habits
ou qui ont d'autres choses à dire
intéressant parce qu'on s'aperçoit que
le modèle qui a existé depuis 20 ans ou
30 ans ou 35 ans ou 40 ans ou 50 ans
mais il a ses limites et que et que et
que si on veut progresser si on veut
améliorer les choses il faut peut-être
gouverner d'une autre manière ou faire
différemment
c'est un point d'interrogation que je
fais mais c'est une réflexion que j'ai
carrière à l'étranger existe-t-il des
pratiques est-ce que vous avez des
pratiques à nous faire remonter des
bonnes pratiques en tout cas sur lequel
on pourrait s'inspirer une chez nous en
France
ouais mais je pense effectivement on
peut toujours aller regarder comment
comment les autres comment les autres
fonctionnent parce que c'est intéressant
aussi de prendre de prendre ce qu'il y a
de bien chez les autres
et ne pas en avoir peur ne pas ne pas ne
pas hésiter mais
je pense que tous les problèmes que nous
évoquons que nous évoquons
j'ai joué en Italie j'ai joué un Espagne
et j'ai joué un Angleterre je peux vous
dire que ces problèmes-là ils sont aussi
présents dans ces dans ces pays-là il
faut pas croire que les autres pays ne
sont ne sont pas soumis à ces problèmes
là
je peux vous dire que j'ai joué en
Italie
dans un pays du sud de l'Italie donc le
racisme en été aussi confronté je peux
le dire
bon après il y a des choses oui il y a
des choses à à je pense regarder et à
comprendre je pense que le football
anglais a été a été
victime de de d'organismes
vous savez que ça me fait beaucoup
beaucoup de mal dans le football puisque
bon c'était c'était quand même très
important je pense qu'ils ont bien fait
ils ont bien réglé donc quand même bien
bien effacer même s'il y a toujours un
corps quelques petits problèmes mais je
pense que ils ont ils ont quand même
fait quelque chose ils ont quand même
été conscient qu'il y avait un problème
qu'il fallait qu'on pouvait plus
continuer comme ça donc je pense que les
Anglais ont quand même fait évoluer dans
le bon sens du terme
ce problème là
comme je vous dis si on a si on a
conscience que voilà il faut faire
évoluer les choses le monde de
gouvernance la responsabilité que vous
voulez responsabilités
[Musique]
à prendre il faut échanger il faut être
comme on dit souvent quand vous avez pas
conscience il y a un problème vous avez
vous risquez pas de le régler le
problème donc on le sait on le sait
on sait ce qui se passe le mode de
fonctionnement il est ce qu'il est on
peut pas le transformer et de changer
radicalement parce que un athlète à mon
avis devra toujours besoin de
l'entraîneur et aura toujours besoin de
de conseils donc il y aura toujours il y
aura toujours mais il faut faire il faut
il faut être il faut être il faut faire
il faut être attentif d'abord
et puis moi je crois aussi beaucoup au
fait que bon voilà les gens commencent à
parler des gens commencent à
informer ça c'est une c'est plutôt une
bonne chose
après il faudrait il faudrait changer
parmi beaucoup de personnes pour essayer
de trouver de prendre les meilleures
solutions pour pour régler ce problème
et ou tout au moins l'améliorer
le corrigé
justement je
vais rebondir sur ce que vous sur ce que
vous dites monsieur blanc
oui j'entends moi j'entends dans
j'entends dans ce que vous dites
qu'effectivement il y a je le disais ce
matin il y a une forme de
malheureuse mais il y a une forme de
fatalisme
pour autant
certes excusez moi fatalisme je trouve
moi je suis je l'ai dit dès le départ je
trouve qu'il y a eu des améliorations
dans ce qui concerne l'éducation des je
prends l'exemple type de public dans un
stade même si le comportement d'un
public actuellement dans le stade n'est
pas n'est pas n'est pas excellent on
n'est pas
irréprochable mais je peux vous dire que
je sais pas si vous aimez le sport mais
si vous rendiez dans un stade il y a 25
ans ou 30 ans ou 10 ans je peux vous
dire qu'on entendait beaucoup plus de
choses beaucoup qu'on voyait beaucoup
plus de choses que maintenant c'est mon
avis
alors pour répondre à votre question non
seulement j'adore le sport mais j'adore
en particulier le football et
je vais vous faire une petite confidence
je suis particulièrement honoré pouvoir
échanger avec Laurent Blanc aujourd'hui
parce que Laurent Blanc il m'a fait
rêver comme comme tous les joueurs de
l'équipe de France 98 non demeure pas
moins
il n'en demeure pas moins qu'on parle de
sujets évidemment sérieux et le football
est un sujet particulièrement sérieux
pour revenir à ce que je disais
auparavant
moi je crois vraiment et ça a été dit
par par d'autres collègues je crois
vraiment que l'effet des rations
les fédérations ont un véritable rôle à
jouer et en particulier évidemment la
Fédération Française de Football alors
permettez-moi cette question si demain
Laurent Blanc ait été élu président de
la Fédération Française de Football que
mettrait-il en œuvre pour que il peut
pas pourquoi il peut pas être c'est ça
un peu de science-fiction imaginons que
vous soyez les élus à la présidence de
la Fédération Française de Football
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est-ce que vous
feriez qu'est-ce que vous feriez très
concrètement une ou deux ou trois
mesures pour faire en sorte qu'on
peut-être pas éradique malheureusement
mais qu'on diminue de manière très
drastique à la fois les violences faites
vis-à-vis des enfants et puis les propos
des propos discriminatoires dont on
vient de parler
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire selon
vous peut-être que c'est des relations
meilleures avec le ministère de
ministère de tutelle mais forcément
forcément
mais permettez-moi et vous me l'avez
vous me l'avez bien lancée alors c'est
pas je pense pas que ça a été volontaire
de votre part mais c'est impossible
d'être élu président de la Fédération
française de football ou dans la prière
de la Présidente c'est le système
électoral ne vous permet pas un
personnage qui se présente et qui a les
bonnes intentions qui a des très bonnes
intentions comme tout les candidats là
aussi c'est un sujet peut-être de
conversation alors que qui n'étaient pas
prévu mais le mode le mode électoral de
pour être élu à la présidence de d'une
fédération il y a des choses à dire il y
a des choses à dire parce que quand vous
dites oui si ou demain vous êtes élu
président de la Fédération française
ce que je voulais pardonnez-moi ce que
je voulais exprimer ce que je voulais
exprimer c'est pas c'est pas de savoir
si oui ou non vous pouviez être élu
président de la Fédération française de
football mais si mais c'est si vous
l'étiez si je peux que vous ne puissiez
pas l'être qu'est-ce que vous feriez
vous avec l'expérience qui est la vôtre
la carrière qui est la vôtre la
notoriété qui est la vôtre pour faire
changer les choses c'est ça que je c'est
ça le sens de ma question et puisque
vous avez j'ai la parole vous évoquez un
autre sujet moi je voudrais vous dire
que j'ai un désaccord avec vous sur
l'amélioration
l'amélioration des choses quand vous
dites avant c'était on entendait des
cris et des et des propos dans les dans
les tribunes et aujourd'hui ce sont les
joueurs et les arbitres qui les tiennent
pardonnez-moi mais je considère et je
fréquente assez régulièrement
un stade dans tous les cas le plus près
de mon domicile
si tel est le cas moi je l'ai pas
forcément constaté mais je vous fais
entièrement confiance là-dessus si tel
est le cas je trouve assez inquiétant
pour tout vous dire qu'effectivement on
n'est pas su faire
œuvre de pédagogie suffisamment forte
pour qu'à la fois les arbitres et les
joueurs ne tiennent pas ce type de
propos donc je crois enfin en tous les
cas en ce qui me concerne je pense pas
qu'on soit vers une amélioration
alors je vais vous répondre je vais
essayer de vous répondre à tout sur la
dernière question
oui effectivement vous avez dit il y a
des arbitres des joueurs mais quand il y
a des arbitres et des joueurs on le sait
parce que il y a des micros où il y a
les joueurs le rapport je pense
sincèrement que
ça existait certainement avant
ça existait avant mais mais dès qu'il y
a des propos
limite racistes entre joueurs entre
arbitre on le sait
seul problème c'est que un stade de
football c'est pas que le terrain c'est
pas que le carré vert il y en a d'autres
il y a le public à mon avis le public
est dura éduqué là-dessus et que et
c'est pour ça que je disais que il me
semblait qu'il y ait une amélioration
durant ces 30 dernières années vis-à-vis
du public même si tout n'est pas parfait
pour ce moment là c'est pour ça pour
sanctionner c'est une amélioration
peut-être pour
identifier et mieux sanctionner
identifier parce que quand c'est un
joueur quand c'est un joueur ou un
arbitre qui tient des propos racistes on
le sait de suite
on le sait maintenant on le sait avant
avant avant le c'est pas comme mais
maintenant maintenant que ça arrive on
le sait parce que le joueur le dénonce
parce que parce que parce que et et ils
ont raison de les dénoncer et c'est pour
ça que je répondais donc oui catégorique
qu'il faut arrêter encore plus si c'est
un arbitre ou un joueur
mais je dirais même quand c'est le
public il faut arrêter il faut arrêter
le il faut arrêter le match il faut
arrêter le la manifestation sportive ça
c'est ça c'est pour ça que je disais que
il y avait une amélioration je voyais
une amélioration des problèmes il y en a
il y en a il y en a malheureusement la
deuxième chose c'est que je pense pour
la Fédération la Fédération quand vous
me dites
oui si vous étiez président de la
Fédération je vous dis que c'est
impossible vous le savez très bien parce
que le système électoral d'un président
de fédération il est très particulier il
est très particulier et je pense
sincèrement que il y aurait des choses
attention mais je me prends pas pour un
autre je ça doit être très difficile
d'être président de la Fédérale de
fédération soit de football de tennis de
natation c'est très difficile parce que
vous avez une responsabilité maintenant
qui devient qui devient très très très
important
et je pense aussi que bon voilà dans le
monde c'est dégrad dans le système dans
le système électoral qui a été qui a été
mise en place il me semble que
ça c'est encore que mon avis c'est que
il est dans beaucoup de fédération il y
a des présidents qui sont omnipotent et
et donc et donc je pense que ça ça
facilite peut-être pas aussi les choses
donc qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire si
j'étais président de la Fédération
Française de Football je n'ose pas
imaginer parce que bon je pense que
c'est pas c'est impossible et que et que
croyez-moi c'est quand même une
responsabilité
assez forte dans la mesure où bon comme
je vous l'ai dit dans toutes les
fédérations dans toutes les secteurs
d'activités
car malheureusement il se passe des
choses à ce moment-là votre
responsabilité est engagée
donc
il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont monsieur
blanc
pour justement sur sur le propos que
vous avez par rapport à la Fédération et
au mode de désignation du président
on vous pose cette question bon votre
surnom en tant que joueur c'était le
président donc c'est normal que mon
collègues
mais vous vous soulevez un très bon
problème il y a énormément de critiques
sur la gouvernance et le mode de
désignation des représentants de la FFF
est-ce que vous vous auriez des
suggestions pour qu'il y a un mode de
désignation qui soit plus on va dire
valorisant notamment pour les clubs
amateurs et que tout le monde se
retrouve dedans et que on n'arrive pas à
des systèmes sclérosés comme vous le
vous l'avez défini
oui oui mais ça on peut on peut on peut
là encore une fois on peut on peut
toujours discuter on peut avoir des avis
qui
divergent mais je trouve que je trouve
qu'un président de fédération qui est un
poste très compliqué je le répète encore
une fois puisque il associe le monde
amateur et le monde professionnel quoi
qu'on en dise
là aussi ce gouvernance
et amateurs d'un côté sous sous la
tutelle du ministère de l'ordre de plus
vite et aussi l'équipe de France qui est
une équipe représentée par les plus gros
professionnels de leur pays il y a aussi
[Musique]
une sorte de de quiproquo de gouvernance
qui fait quoi comment on fait le moment
c'est pas très simple tout ça mais aussi
le fait que bon voilà en termes de
gouvernance vous le savez aussi bien que
moi et je vais pas vous la prendre que
les mandats sont limités les mandats
sont limités que ce soit en politique
que ce soit de partout les mandats sont
limitées jusqu'à preuve du contraire je
pense qu'un président de fédération
alors je sais pas peut-être je me
trompais mais
les mandats d'un président de fédération
ne sont pas limitées il peut il peut
faire
un deux trois quatre cinq six mandats et
vous arrivez avec des présidents qui
sont là depuis 20 25 ans 30 ans et qui
sont au niveau temps quoi donc mais je
parle pas que de la Fédération Française
de Football donc voilà est-ce que c'est
le meilleur
système est-ce que c'est le meilleur
moyen je sais pas il faut en discuter il
faut échanger moi je pense qu'il faut il
faut il faut être déjà conscient de tous
ces problèmes là et que il faut mettre
plein plein plein plein de
d'avertisseur ou d'avertissement
[Musique]
dans l'éducation des jeunes parce qu'on
s'aperçoit qu'il y a il y a une
multitude de problèmes
bah écoutez merci mais peut-être moi je
vais faire une remarque quand même parce
que je pense que je regrette quand même
que dans vos réponses j'ai le sentiment
qu'on soit passé quand même à côté de du
vrai sujet qui est quand même que sous
couvert déjà de la question des
binationaux on a tenté d'écarter des
jeunes français du fait de leur origine
supposée au réel ce ne sont pas des
propos de vestiaires comme vous avez pu
le dire mais des propos de responsables
sportifs de la plus grande fédération
c'est pas anodin juste je vais terminer
puis après vous aurez le loisir de voilà
de rebondir moi je j'avoue que je
m'attendais à
il faut l'attaquer il faut l'attaquer
fort
les binationaux ils sont français et ce
matin à juste titre quand on a
auditionné les journalistes de Mediapart
ils nous ont dit vous savez si cette
sélection ici c'est quotas avait été mis
en place on aurait peut-être pas eu
Kylian Mbappé qui joue aujourd'hui dans
l'équipe de France donc vous voyez c'est
pas c'est pas anodin c'est pour ça que
j'insiste vraiment là-dessus moi je
m'attendais vraiment à autre chose parce
que quand le DTM quand le DTN ou le
sélectionneur je vais je vais terminer
quand le DTN ou le sélectionneur lors
d'une réunion le dit si ça avait pas été
enregistré personne ne l'aurait su mais
pire que cela la seule personne qui a
été sanctionnée c'est finalement la
personne qui a dénoncé l'effet
effectivement l'enregistrant et puis moi
ça me pose vraiment la question de la
responsabilité collective parce que dans
ce cadre là vous voyez bien là c'est
enregistré c'est sûr ça choque mais
finalement on se dit que il y a plein
d'autres réunions où il a pu se dire
plein d'autres choses qui peuvent être
racistes ou discriminantes et en fait on
ne l'a pas su elles n'ont jamais été
sanctionnées elles n'ont jamais été
rendues publiques donc voilà c'est pour
ça que je vous dis moi j'ai quand même
le sentiment
qu'on voilà qui qui a un moment se pose
aussi cette question de responsabilité
collective il y avait plein d'adultes
autour de la table et je pense que il ne
fallait pas attendre que ça soit public
pour le condamner mais que tout propos
raciste ou discriminant se doit d'être
condamné
oui je suis d'accord avec vous
Monsieur Laurent Blanc est-ce que vous
pensez de nous avoir tout dit au cours
de cette audition
je vous ai tout dit par rapport aux
questions qui ont été posées moi
j'aurais aimé j'aurais aimé j'aurais
aimé avoir un peu plus de discussion et
d'échanges sur les sur les sur les
problèmes qui est qui existent encore
aujourd'hui et que cette fameuse réunion
avait soulevé il y a 10 ans
voilà on parle toujours la dame vient de
me parler des binationaux je fais pas
une fixation sur les binationaux mais à
mon avis à mon avis il faut il faut
régler cette question là de choix
il faut rester il faut il faut et on le
fait pas
quand j'ai commencé le football il y en
a toujours eu des débuts nationaux il y
en aura toujours même des tri nationaux
il s'avère que est-ce que est-ce que la
notre notre nationalité sportive nous
avons le choix de le faire mais il faut
faire le choix à mon époque je jouais on
le fait on la faisait à 21 à 21 ans
quand on était en espoir est-ce que
est-ce que est-ce que est-ce qu'on a
changé depuis non et voilà donc on
aurait pu en discuter puisque c'était le
le
sujet de cette réunion
il y a 10 ans
bon écoutez
disant ou 12 ans après
à part vous qui m'avait qui m'avait qui
m'avait appelé pour en discuter pour
échanger il y a personne qui m'a il y a
personne qui a qui a changé avec moi sur
ce sujet là et je pense comme vous
l'avez dit que bon pendant 10 ans on a
mis ce dossier
là à l'écart je pense que c'est pas le
meilleur moyen pour essayer de corriger
et de faire évoluer les choses
vous avez les questions entre les mains
vous savez que vous pouvez compléter vos
propos vous pouvez également formuler
vos propositions et vos réflexions par
écrit par mail à l'adresse que vous avez
donc on compte sur vous bien sûr si vous
avez des propos qui ont été oubliés
aujourd'hui à compléter ces informations
[Musique]
Merci à VOUS oui il y avait le football
féminin aussi il y avait la question
donc écoutez ce sera peut-être pour une
prochaine fois
c'est pas que c'est pas une mission pour
la question c'est juste que nous avons
une audition supplémentaire à 17h c'est
pour ça donc il y a aucune volonté de
même pas de retirer une question très
intéressante sur le football
malheureusement nous avons pas abordé
vous pouvez compléter par écrit
bon bref en tout cas ça a été
très intéressant écoutez merci merci de
m'avoir convoqué finalement
merci Monsieur Laurent Blanc Merci à
VOUS bonne
après-midi au revoir bonne soirée à vous